step by step *jumpscare* WAUGH!!!!!
*keemstar news intro*
Welcome to the game! :D
Whats that?
Whe game is called welcome to the g-
Welcome to the game?
WELCOME TO THE GAME!!!
Today we're going to play: welcome to the game
What's dat?
The game it's called: welcome to the game?
WELCOME TO THE..VIDRRRREO
Today we gonna play welcome to the game
It's a game about hacking and jumpscares
That's aLL I KNOW
Let's get ROOOOOOOOOIIIIIIIII
Fuck off (keem eat yo heart out)
This game will play with your minds
This game will fuck with ya
This game don't play by rules
New game please
So this game you go into the "deep web"
The deep web is basically an area on the internet, only accessed through an encrypted browser
Omg i can look
I got a call
A aaadam
*adam speaking* Hey yeah so
Are you sure you want to do this?
The deep web is full of fucked up shi-
*pewds* That's what I was saying!
*adam*There are some things you cant unsee
like his DEE-
Now, I don't know anything about the deep web, of course
cause it's illegal
But I heard is filled with illegal activities
Child porn
*pewds reflects on his choice of words*
Now it just sounds like I go there for that
great job poods (naughty boi)
*adam* -you can't access these sites on a normal browser
*sherlock* -Notes is well... uh Notes!
well written...
WELL written..
WHAT
OMG I CAN CLICK OUT
Ooooo this is the kinda game you wanna play in VR
*adam* When you explore the deep web, you're exposed to hackers.
These hackers will attempt to hack you. (no shit)
*pewds* Ok so you can get DDoSed in this game
*adam* I'm gonna go ahead and launch a Dos attack-
OMG IM GETTING HACKED
*INTENSE FUCKIN MUSIC*
OH       PC: HA HA HA HAAAAAAA
Wut?
Oh god I gotta hack
Ahh
You go there
And you go-
There we go
You go down
There it is!
Hack blocked I'm an excellent hacker
I'm an excellent hacker *sure dude*
I'm a better hacker than
DYLAN
*adam* -there are kidnappers that will try to locate and kidnap you O.O
WHAT?
This is just like real life!
Alright bros
You ready to enter the deep web? *thats what she said*
I'm a little scared
Maybe the cops will see this video
*Keyboard tapping furiously*
Let's see what do we got
Oh shit
OoooOoo the deep wiki
This is real guys
This is fucking real
You can buy drugs
Get some drug-
You want some- You want some drugs?
Hey man
Oh fucka mucka shit
OH GOD WERE GETTING HACKED
WE'RE GETTING HACKED
This is freaking me out oh god
We're getting DDosed
Fuck (x5)
Hack them back
You got BLLLLOCKED
Let's get some cannabis
*snorts*
OH CMON MAN
Oh god we're getting- Uhh what the fuck I gotta type all this
I have a swedish keyboard
I don't fucking knoww
*furious typing*
I'm being such a
FUCK
I don't fucking kno-
Look at my key-
GODDAMIT
It's freaking me out
Hack blocked
God this is fucking weird man
Herro?
Is that my neighbours?
Alright let's get some cheap cigarettes
*pewds no its bad for ur lungs*
God fuck
CAN'T DO ANYTHING THESE DAYS
OK we're in!
muscleboy81
*creepy footsteps in the game*
What was that?
*another creepy footstep*
*another one*
No O.O
Herro?
Fuck me thats scary
I'm legit freaked out man
This is so fucking weird
This is some illuminati sign shit isn't it
Dufuq is disss
Oookay
Dats an iris
OOOooooooooOOOO
Now that-
Lemme get some Opioids
Cmon
Cmon man where the fuck do I get drugs
I want DRUGS DAMMIT
I'm a youtuber
We have to get into...
The ecstasy
Double up
SHIT
All  these fucking twelve-year olds tryna DDos me
woah
What the FUCk
*reads note*
What the fuck is all this?
Did someone just fucking smash their head on the keyboard?
Either that or they cleaned it
I'm gonna have to go with option two
*epic music*
Oh fuck I'm getting hacked again ;-;
Fucking swedish keyboard
(no pewds thats my job)
What the fuck was that sound?
*creepy chair moving sound*
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT??!
Oh my god ;-;
This is freaking-
OOOoooooOOooooOOooOoOo (that face HAHA)
*tarzan*
Hey :D
Yess
I mean I need to defend myself from all the hackers
I'll buy that one
And that one
What is this-
*creepy sound*
What the fuck was that?!
Herro?
I can't- I can't tell if its in the game or not
Its fucking weird
*poods brings sum coffee* (whos behind him??)
SHIT
*evil laughter*
I don't know how to make that fucking thing
FUCKING SWEDISH KEYBOARD
Oh fuck me it scared me
Jesus
Oh my god you swedish son of a bitch
*evil laughter*
*pewds fed up with this game's bullshit*
Man I having so much fun
What a great game you suggested
Boom!
Y'all got fucked
*creepy sounds*
What the fuck was that?!1!
They're after me
Oh fuck
I was typiNG
Okay
We got a URL
Let's try-
Can I open a new tab
Please work
What
Oh we prgressed! :D
NUDE YOUTUBERS !1!!
(that face xD)
DAMMIT
FUCK
Alright
We're coming back
Ohh-
Ahh
NO I SPILLED MY COFFEE ;-;
EUUGHHHH
Goddamit
This fucking game is putting me on edge mAN
Shit fucking ass
All over my keyboa- All over my keyboard
Y'know what it's coffee ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
*snorts coffee*
whaaAAAATT
*demonic whispers*
What was that?
*demonic whispers intensify*
O my godDD
Oh no nooOOOOOO
Fuu-
(unholy thoughts)
Are you kidding mee??
*creepy footstep sound*
*another creepy footstep*
Who's doing-
MOM
MOM go back to bedd
Family drug shop :D
*adorable laugh*
Good ol' family drug shop
I would like some speed :D
That's how I do my videos
I've always wanted to be kidnapped
And
Raped ;-;
...And the thought of
Kidnapping me
And raping me
Turns me on so much D:
I plan to amputate my left arm
And replace it with my dead lover's
Arm D:
I have this fantasy of breaking into someone's house
And pee on all of the most valued-
(pewds that's my JOB)
YEAH YOU BETTER NOT COME INTO MY HOUSE AND PEE
*cleans nose*
Ayyy the Butcher
Step by step
*jumpscare*
AHH
Dufuq was that? xD
I play the game for over an hour
And then it fucking jumpscares me outta nowhere
Thanks
Thanks a-fucking-lot
Uuhhwell
That was Welcome To The Game
A very interseting game
Not that fun to play *winks*
Hopefully the video was fun anyway (yes it was)
Leave a like if you enjoyed
I'm not touching this shit again
See you bros tomorrow
With a fresh new video
And as always
*kisses fist*
Stay awesome bros~